(fast drumming)
(fast hard rock music)
- The world of sound that is created by
so many musicians is so strong
that you get goosebumps.
You get slaps on your face
and punched in the stomach.
It's very, very intense and powerful.
I'm not really able to translate it
into words; you just have to see it.
My name is Fabio Zaffagnini,
and I'm the founder
of Rockin'1000 ...
The biggest rock band on earth.
Rockin'1000 is a band
composed of thousands
and thousands of musicians coming from
all over the world.
We organize massive events
where more than a thousand
musicians perform simultaneously.
We have 400 guitars,
250 drummers, 300 bassists,
350 singers.
We have musicians coming
from 30 different countries
in the world:
from South Korea, from the United States,
from Canada, from Brazil, Russia, Iran.
(rock music)
The logistic challenge is quite big.
Hundreds and hundreds of people
build the stage, which is
as big as a football field.
We have hundreds of microphones,
miles and miles of wires and cables.
It's crazy.
All the musicians have to prepare
from home, and once they come here,
they will have like
three days of rehearsals-
very intense days.
They get to meet each other.
They start playing and meld together
and build the magic.
The main message behind
Rockin'1000 is the spirit
of togetherness.
The idea that people
that generally play in their basement
or sing under the shower,
when they're all together,
they can really make the difference
and it's a message that goes
far beyond music, I think.
We make no difference of
the sexual orientation,
political orientation,
religious orientation,
rich or poor, professionals or newbies.
We include everybody.
They're all together
because of rock and roll.
(hard rock music)